welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and the new loki trailer released
at disney investor day was the most
puzzling rubik's cube of marvel lore
and pop culture conspiracy that mcu fans
have seen in years
suggesting that the god of mischief is
the madman behind historical mysteries
like db cooper and the polybius game
as a student of conspiracy thinking
myself my shot by shot breakdown of that
trailer was one of my favorite videos
that i've ever done in new rockstars but
despite all the cool stuff that i found
there are
even more hidden clues that when you
decipher these
actually do start to line up what the
hell this series will be
so let's shift forward now from our
discovery investigation phase to
analysis what is loki who is this
version of loki and to paraphrase drax
why is loki the trailer reminds us that
loki escaped avengers in game during the
time heist sequence stealing the fumbled
tesseract
space stone in 2012 and zipping away to
some unknown destination the trailer's
editing
tricks us into thinking he then traveled
in a bifrost like wormhole
until being spit back out in the
mongolian gobi desert but
not so fast loki no longer has the mouth
restraint and cuffs that he had
the moment of his departure and he does
not appear to have the tesseract in that
desert
and as an experienced teleporter via the
tesseract in the bifrost he would not
have crash landed in some accidental
region like this
so what really happened on the other
side of loki's in-game escape remains a
mystery but
we know that he ends up in the hands of
the tva that is the time
variants authority the timeline
investigators of the marvel comics
owen wilson plays according to the
closed captioning mobius
m mobius a recurring tva agent in the
comics
his name connects to the geometric shape
of a mobius strip which was actually
referenced in
end game when tony stark cracks the code
of time travel this time
in the shape of a mobius strip inverted
please the inverted mobius strip is a
two dimensional planner
ribbon twisting and smoothly looping
back on itself keep that in mind for
later so the tva is detaining loki
because he
is the out-of-place smoking gun of the
avengers screwing with this timeline
that allowed him to cheat
death he was supposed to die six years
later in that timeline
that is what mobius is showing him here
projections of his arrest in avengers in
and then later that timeline's version
of loki involved in the ragnarok event
in 2017
which of course would lead to his
appointment with the world's first
chiropractor in infinity war
if that makes you cringe hey look you
got something in common with loki mobius
brings loki in front of a time court
presided over by gugu mabathara as some
kind of judge
in the comics there's tva judges like
justice peace justice love justice
goodwill but behind her are these three
faces which is where we're gonna do some
analyzing beyond what i did in the
breakdown because in the breakdown i
wondered if these three could represent
the multiple faces of the living
tribunal a cosmic judge who we have been
waiting to see coming to the mcu for a
while
but these are actually the time keepers
tva figures created by the final tba
agent at the end of all time
named he who remains their function is
to teach
future members of the next universal
cycle how to avoid the errors of the
past
and to be kind of living batteries of
coronal power
time energy accumulated to support tba
retirees
i know it's great right the problem is
in the comics the timekeeper's creation
also creates the time twisters another
trio who
end up screwing up the multiverse until
they are eventually stopped by
thor and other avengers because as
guardians as
near immortals are able to resist the
time manipulation powers of the
timekeepers and the time twisters
and that clues us into why this court
needs
loki as an asgardian loki can resist the
restrictions of time manipulation
and travel across timelines as adeptly
as members of the tva can
that is what mobius meant by time passes
differently here in the tva
what does that mean you'll catch up i
think the tva
and this time court is giving loki an
opportunity to escape conviction for his
timeline violation
by helping them with an assignment that
only he can fulfill that assignment
to find and stop another worse time
criminal now i'm assuming this loki plot
is going this way partially
because the showrunner of loki is rick
and morty writer mark waldron and this
all reminds me a lot of the council of
rick's episode when rick is dragged into
court and has to clear his name by
hunting down a way more evil rick who
ends up being a puppet of a way more
evil morty anyway in loki's case
the even worse time criminal is also
himself but
an alternate reality female form lady
loki
we believe this is sophia dimartino's
character she is the one in the hood
she is the one sitting on the planet
about to be crushed by a moon now i'm
not making this up lady loki has a basis
in the marvel comics after the ragnarok
event in the comics loki's soul follows
the natural cycle of norse myth
and returns in a new body this time a
female form and if we follow that logic
to the mcu
after loki died in infinity war his
spirit could have left his corpse and
then come back
in the body of a female in fact in the
trailer we see
a young girl who could be a young
version of that lady loki and as another
asgardian
lady loki would be able to resist the
control of the timekeepers
bringing loki back this way would
fulfill loki's promise to thor
i assure you brother the sun will shine
on us again
and preserve both phases of loki's
character development in the mcu the
dastardly 2012 trickster
and the somewhat redeemed 2018 anti-hero
and while 2018 loki seemed to come a
long way in terms of his morality
let's face it folks he's still a dirty
bastard who likely would have gone
through
a lot in a post-blip universe think
about it waking
up in a female body after the snap he
might have just thought
screw it the world's on fire and honey
you
trailer footage shows her sitting on a
planet seemingly awaiting death
and then another shot shows loki running
across that planet surface as this
cracked moon crashes down on them
maybe we are seeing the very end of the
universe lady loki could be
she who remains and loki has to save her
to figure out all the ways she messed up
the timeline maybe she created those
time keepers to begin with and then now
they need to destroy the consequences
that could be why loki promised to
mobius while they were sitting in the
tva
i'm gonna burn this place to the ground
so how does loki find her how do the
time travel mechanics of this show work
well before i continue thanks to
expressvpn for sponsoring this video
do you feel like you're not able to
access all the content you would like to
on the internet
are you worried about hackers and
scammers stealing your information you
should be
and if so expressvpn is your solution
expressvpn is a virtual private network
that encrypts your data to keep it from
being stolen or tracked and it can grant
you access to blocked content
like netflix in the uk has content that
us netflix doesn't have like
south park or rick and morty at this
point you've probably watched everything
on your country's version of netflix
right
imagine getting a whole new batch of
content without having to pay for
another streaming service
expressvpn allows you to reroute your
internet connection to a server in a
country of your choice
making geo restrictions a thing of the
past expressvpn is also helpful for
preventing your online data from being
stolen or monitored without your
knowledge
i really like expressvpn because their
servers operate at the
fastest speeds and it is super easy to
use no confusion no wasted time
just fire up the app and connect with
just one click it is the top rated vpn
provider rated number one by techradar
cnet and many more
find out how you can get three months
free by clicking the link in the
description box below
expressvpn.comrockstars again that's
expressvpn.com
new rockstars well they seem to all be
related to this elevator where there are
seemingly random
three character floor designations and
buttons in the middle that might
correspond to how to travel from
timeline to timeline
or what to do to those timelines i
started going into this in the breakdown
when loki mobius and the chrono monitors
raid that rocks cart they arrive
through these glowing rectangular
portals which i assume is what those
elevator doors look like on the other
side
in the destination timeline now there's
this redditor zac kwasick
who attempted to decode these with an
alphanumeric substitution to
multiplication by 10 or 100
to try to derive numeric designations of
known marvel realities there's a great
attempt i love that other people like
this exist
but so far this system isn't really
consistently applied the results are all
over the place
still good work in the meantime i'm
sticking with my theory that the three
characters correspond to the three
dimensions of space
imagine an x a y and a z axis they
represent a point somewhere in
three-dimensional space
theoretical physicists like einstein
suggested that to travel
through time or to teleport across
three-dimensional space we would have to
bend a three-dimensional space and
puncture a hole in it this is called a
wormhole or an einstein-rosen bridge
more like a rainbow fringe
so to visualize this for you with some
amazing prop design we got
fe3 here it's a xy and a z-axis a point
in three-dimensional space
and then we also got l k and three
another point three-dimensional space to
connect these you would have to kind of
bend three dimensional space on itself
and then try to connect them
so we've got time travel and we got
time travel this hole that it just
punches is a fourth dimensional
axis on that grid and it is the
dimension of time it's kind of
impossible for us as three-dimensional
beings to perceive
but yeah it's kind of like that boom
this is the elevator shaft like whatever
christopher nolan tried to convey this
with a tesseract
interstellar loki is simplifying it with
a wonka vader it's very elegant very
douglas adams i love it but
our 2012 loki is not going to play by
the rules and that is how we end up with
the madcap cluster
that we see in this trailer loki appears
in a post-apocalyptic new york you can
actually see avengers tower there we can
interpret this as loki
living in a version of earth if his
chittari invasion in the first avengers
movie was successful now we know loki
will go back to that because
notice this moment in the trailer
glorious
that mirror is in the penthouse of stark
tower and if you look closely in the
reflection
loki is carrying the scepter there he is
giving himself a redo for that battle
we also see shots of loki in that trashy
lair there's the throne with the l
over it and he's all done up with a torn
suit and a loki for president pin
we might be looking at that same
dystopian post-loki victory future where
thanos might have left loki in charge of
earth and loki as he did in the vote
loki comics so great he convinces
america to elect him on the message that
he had the balls to lie to them
also in the breakdown i pointed out two
historical mysteries this trailer is
suggesting loki is behind
obviously there's the db cooper thing
with loki being suggested as that
mystery airline hijacker who parachuted
out with 200 000
and was never found turns out heimdall
helped him out with that and then
there's the polybius game
an apocryphal arcade game that tech
bloggers claim
existed in the 80s hypnotizes players
and was part of some government
conspiracy to study gamers
both very cool details but another
detail i spotted in this trailer was
loki in some mystery setting with roman
numerals on a nearby wall equating 279
and i cannot believe i didn't put this
together at the time because i swear to
one of the historical mysteries i
actually thought about while
i was writing that breakdown script was
the famous latin seder square the
inspiration for another christopher
nolan film tenet
that palindromic matrix seder arrepoe
tenet opera rhodus has no verified
translation no one knows what it means
it's just a cool palindrome that works
in multiple dimensions but a few of
those
were recovered in the ruins of pompeii
which was destroyed in a volcanic
eruption
in the year 79 a.d
loki is in pompeii there folks and yes
another mystery the loki series will
explore the final days of pompeii
and even perhaps the mystery of that
seder square relic that even christopher
nolan couldn't make sense of that my
friends is why i
am so freaking pumped for this series
it's the true
mcu time heist that i actually wanted
from endgame but with one of my favorite
characters taking cues from rick and
morty and hitchhiker's guide to the
galaxy
intersecting with real world conspiracy
theories in urban myths don't be
surprised if i make 100 videos about it
between now and may you think i'm an
idiot for bringing up mephisto so much
and want to vision video as well
mephisto's
and loki and i haven't even gotten to
that yet but you can support my insanity
by checking out our wonderful merch
store newrockstarsmerch.com lots of
great stuff to buy there
follow me at eaboss follow new rockstars
thank you for watching
boom
[Music]
you